bonsoir bienvenue dans le 78 politique
spécial Europe les élections européennes
se déroulent tous les 5 ans sur un seul
tour et pour ce scrutin la date en
France a été fixé au 25 mai c'est c'est
donc dans à peu près 2 semaines depuis
1979 les putés qui siègeent au Parlement
européen sont élus au suffrage universel
direct alors dans le courant de cette
émission nous évoquerons le rôle et le
travail du Parlement européen et je vous
proposerai également une immersion au
sein de la Commission européenne c'est à
Bruxelles mais donc d'abord on va
aborder avec mon invité Olivier janx
bonsoir le rôle du Parlement européen
Olivier vous vous officiez au sein de
Europe Direct Eveline c'est la
représentation on peut dire régionale de
l'Union européenne c'est ça voilà en
fait Europe Direct c'est un réseau
d'information mis en place par la
Commission européenne qui vise à
renseigner les citoyens sur toutes les
questions qui peuvent se poser en
général sur l'Union européenne al pour
le zine s'est installé à Versailles et
pour les téléspectateurs assidu on peut
vous retrouver tous les soirs puisque
vous animez une chronique sur téléfil
consacré justement à à l'Europe et vous
l'Europe au quotidien alors actuellement
le Parlement européen ce sont 766
députés qui sont élus dans 28 pays et la
France compte sur ces 766 députés 74
députés à partir du dimanche 25 mA je
l'ai dit ce sont les élections euréenne
sur un seul tour cette fois on ne va
élire que 751 députés il y en aura moins
effectivement 751 députés parce que tout
simplement les traités ont été modifiés
tout simplement il y a des nouvelles
règles de représentation donc ce qui
fait que certains pays vont perdre des
députés d'autres pays vont en gagner
pour d'autes il ne change rien c'est cas
de la France puisque la France touour de
74 députés comment se passent ces
élections européenne on vote par
circonscription la France est divisée en
H circonscriptions alors la France est
divisée en en plusieurs en plusieurs
circonscriptions donc pour celles qui
nous intéressent c'est la
circonscription d'Île-de-France et des
Français de l'étranger donc 15 € 15 €
députés à élire pour l'île-de-fance et
les eurodéputés à l'étranger voilà il y
a 800 circonscription en tout et la
nouveauté effectivement cette année
c'est que la circonscription de l'île
de- France englobe aussi les Français de
de l'étranger exactement parce que avant
sur l'ancienne circonscription on avait
uniquement la circonscription Île de
France on avait 13 € députés vu que
maintenant les les Français à l'étranger
sont aout sont ajoutés à cette
circonscription on passe à 15 alors là
on voit effectivement sur ce ce
graphique la répartition des députés
français des 74 députés français en
fonction de leur appartenance politique
en France on le voit le parti
majoritaire c'est celui du du PPE c'est
l'équivalent de la droite et du centre
il y a 15 eurod députés qui sont verts
il y a 14 qui sont notamment socialistes
pour ces élections européennes c'est ce
qui est peut-être un peu compliqué pour
les électeurs de s retrouver d'abord
c'est à un seul tour exactement voilà
donc il faut faut aller voter dimanche
25 sinon après ce sera tr trop tard et
puis surtout il y a énormément de listes
pour cette la circonscription d'î- de
France et des Français de l'étranger il
y a 31 listes pourqu autant de listes
c'est fréquence he d'avoir autant de
listes ben non c'est pas fréquence c'est
peut-être un signe que l'Europe
intéresse et que tout simplement c'est
vrai qu'on nous dit souvent l'Europe
c'est loin l'Europe on y comprend rien
mais 31 liste ça montre quand même que
les Français sont intéressés mais
surtout c'est que le Parlement européen
est élu à la proportionnel ce qui veut
tout simplement dire que les petits les
petits partis ont leur chance alors
c'est peutêtre pour ça ça explique qu'il
y a autant de listes qui soit présent on
les voit défiler effectivement il y en a
31 on pe pu faire des des placards on a
fait un déroulé parce que ça prend
effectivement du temps maintenant de de
de les voir effectivement défiler alors
l'une des
principales nouveautés de ce scrutin
c'est que lorsque les les États-membres
vont désigner le prochain président de
la Commission européenne actuellement
c'est Emmanuel José Manuel Barroso il
faudra tenir compte justement des
résultats de ces élections européennes
au Parlement européen ça c'est vraiment
nouveau effectivement c'est nouveau
c'est une une des principales nouveautés
qui a été introdu dans le traité de
Lisbonne les états vont devoir tenir
compte des résultats du Parlement
c'est-à-dire que la majorité qui va se
dégager au Parlement de cette majorité
sortira un candidat voilà donc
c'est-à-dire que si on a une majorité
qui est plus à droite le prochain
président de la Commission européenne
sera à droite si c'est une majorité qui
est à gauche le président sera à gauche
c'était pas le cas auparavant non avant
c'était pas le cas c'était pas le cas
parce que tout simplement les états
choisissaient le candidat qui les
intéressait donc on a eu pendant de
mandats de suite José Emmanuel Barosso
c'était un candidat qui arrivait à peu
près à faire consensus entre tous les
états c'était les États qui faisaient un
peu leur soupe de leur côté maintenant
euh la décision a été prise d'impliquer
davantage les citoyens dans le processus
de décision h donc ça veut dire que est
vraiment le le citoyen quand il va
mettre son petit btin dans l'urne la
couleur politique demain du Parlement
aura un effet direct sur la Commission
européenne alors justement oui de
manière très concrète ça veut dire que
le parti euh qui remportera qui aura le
plus de voix verra sa tête de liste euh
propulsé président de la Commission
européenne d'accord alors tous les
partis n'ont pas des têtes de liste hein
certains partis ont déjà définis qui
serait tête de liste et qui serait
candidat à la commission européen et
d'autres partis qui ont pas choisi leur
tête de liste alors là s'ils sont élus
ça ils sont majoritaires ça peut-être
être un peu compliqué non oui c'est
c'est compliqué alors c'est sûr que euh
on sait très bien que il y a cinq partis
il y a CIN les cinq grands partis ont
présenté euh leur tête de liste donc
pour pour la Gauche Unitaire nous avons
Alexis cypras le grec pour les Verts
nous avons skakeller qui est allemande
pour le PSE donc l'équivalent PS en
France c'est Martin Schulz l'actuel
président du Parlement européen pour la
DLE c'est plus le modem en France nous
avons donc l'eurodéputé Guy verofstad et
pour le PPE équivalent UMP en France
c'est Jean-Claude Junker ouais tout à
fait alors justement le Parlement
européen à pas confondre avec la
Commission européenne le Conseil de
l'Europe ça ça fait bien des
institutions quel est le rôle du
Parlement européen là où siègent les les
les futurs 751 députés le Parlement le
rôle du Parlement européen est de
représenter les citoyens auprès des
institutions européennes et notamment
lors du vote euh de ce qu'on appelle les
lois européennes parce que au niveau du
euh au niveau de pour faire simple les
lois européennes sont présentées par la
Commission européenne et voté dans les
mêmes termes par le Parlement européen
qui représente les citoyens et le
Conseil de l'Union européenne qui
représente les états voilà et donc le
rôle du Parlement européen donc les
Européens ne proposent pas de loi le
Parlement c'est la Commission européenne
qui propose les lois alors
officiellement la Commission européenne
propose les lois
mais c'est officiellement donc
officieusement il y a toujours des
petits arrangements entre eux donc
officieusement de nombreux de nombreuses
eurodéputés en fait font passer leur
texte à la Commission européenne donc
juste une petite statistique en fait il
y a à peu près 40 % des textes qui sont
d'initiative qui sont d'inspiration
parlementaire 40 % des textes qui sont
d'inspiration étatique et seulement à
peu près 20 % qui sont effectivement
d'inspiration de la commission ah oui
alors alors qu'officiellement c'est
plutôt la commission qui qui fixe les
qui fixe les les lois donc il propose
des lois ils votent les lois ils ont
aussi un rôle de contrôle ces députés
européens effectivement les institions
le Parlement a un rôle de contrôle donc
principalement au niveau de la
Commission européenne parce que tout
simplement la Commission le Parlement
européen approuve le choix de la
la Commission européenne et son
président il peut aussi la censurer donc
comme au niveau de la France la motion
de censure ça c'est un classique euh le
le Parlement européen peut aussi poser
des questions notamment au niveau du
Conseil de l'Union européenne et de la
commission donc là aussi c'est pour
vérifier que les États font bien leur
travail et aussi lorsque dans certains
cas les états font un peu cavalier seul
dans leur coin pour pour les rappeler à
l'ordre pour leur dire voilà le
Parlement européen veille et aussi à
chaque réunion du Conseil européen le
Parlement européen présente la position
du Parlement européen pour dire voilà ce
que les citoyens attendent des état
lorsqu'ils se réunissent au niveau du
Conseil européen d'accord ouis c'est
vraiment assez complexe un droit de
regard aussi sur le budget européen sur
effectivement le Parlement euré son
vérifier les finances comment il
dépenser l'argent parce que c'est
toujours la grande question sur l'Europe
comment il dépenser l'argent où va
l'argent alors tout simplement le le
Parlement européen va voter le budget ou
du moins va voter la répartition du
budget si vous voulez les États en fait
vont apporter l'enveloppe financière ils
vont dire voilà on va mettre tant
d'euros tant de milliards d'euros dans
le budget donc ça ce sont les États qui
décident mais la répartition tant vont
être accordés à l'éducation tant vont
être accordés à la compétitivité des
entreprises tant vont être accordés à
l'environnement ça sur cette répartition
là le Parlement européen a à vote vote
en la matière et donc il faut il faut
bien comprendre que le Parlement
européen en la matière a le dernier mot
ce qui d'ailleurs peut entraîner parfois
de d'apres négociation entre le
Parlement européen et les états parce
que le par Parlement européen va
toujours essayer de faire en sorte en
bloquant ce vote d'essayer de faire en
sorte de monter l'enveloppe qui va être
attribuée au budget européen alors quand
on voit l'importance du Parlement
européen comment on peut expliquer le
taux d'abstention qui est extrêmement
fort il était de 59 % en France pour les
dernières élections européennes alors il
en plus il y a 31 les donc il y a
vraiment là pour le coup il y a vraiment
du choix comment on peut à votre avis on
peut expliquer ça ben un l'urope est
trop loin du des Français non l'Europe
n'est pas trop loin l'Europe on la voit
tous les on la voit tous les jours
d'ailleurs
on on en parle voilà donc ça on on en
parle tous les jours non c'est que c'est
surtout un manque de communication euh
dans dans les médias principalement je
veux dire on entend souvent les on voit
souvent dans les médias les les
incidents de séance au niveau de
l'Assemblée nationale au niveau du
Parlement français mais au niveau de du
Parlement européen non faut bien
comprendre que le Parlement européen
n'est pas n'a pas une culture de clash
de buzz c'est plus une culture de
travail ce qui fait que c'est une
présence moins médiatique le parlement
européen fait un travail qui est
beaucoup plus technique et donc moins
passionnant ouais donc c'est un peu plus
austère c'est peut-être pour ça que ça
passionne pas forcément un dernier mot
Olivier jendex sur le Europe Direct vous
n avez dit c'est vraiment pour
renseigner les citoyens sur toutes les
questions européennes exactement donc
bon nous principalement du fait qu'on
est dans un centre d'information
jeunesse c'est des jeunes qui viennent
principalement nous voir pour tout ce
qui est les questions d'études de stage
à l'étranger mais on répond sur vraiment
toutes les questions voilà donc il ne
faut pas hésiter à nous solliciter si si
les citoyens ont des questions ils ne
doivent pas hésiter ando qui s'affiche
avec les coordonnées téléphoniques si
effectivement on veut contacter Europe
Direct Yveline puisque'il y a une
représentation de l'Union européenne
dans les Yvelines elle se trouve à
Versailles merci beaucoup Olivier janex
d'être venu sur le plateau de de télfil
pour nous expliquer le rôle du Parlement
européen on comprend bien que ces
élections sont extrêmement importantes
et qu'elles auront évidemment un effet
sur le président ou la présidente
peut-être du futur de la future
Commission européenne alors maintenant
je vous je propose justement d'en savoir
un peu plus sur le rôle de cette
commission européenne avec Patrick JAC
de dixm nous nous sommes rendus à
Bruxelles nous avons également abordé la
question délicate du budget de
l'unionunion européenne et des aides
particulières accordées par
l'Union le 25 mai prochain ce sont les
élections européennes il s'agit donc
d'élir les députés européens ils sont au
nombre de 751 dont 74 pour la France les
députés qui siègent au Parlement
européen qui lui se trouve à Strasbourg
et nous nous nous trouvons à Bruxelles
devant la Commission européenne une
commission qui est chargée de définir
les lois c'est donc une institution
importante que je vous propose de
découvrir allez
suivez-moi alors on va essayer de
comprendre évidemment un peu mieux les
le fonctionnement de l'Europe avec vous
Marc Tak gradani bonjour on se trouve
donc ici à la Commission européenne et
puis derrière nous on a les photos des
fameux commissaires européens il y en a
28 commission présidée par José Manuel
Barroso parmi les commissaires on a un
Français mich Michel Barnier d'abord la
Commission européenne elle sert à quoi
alors le le le principal rôle de de de
la Commission européenne c'est de
représenter l'intérêt général donc de
considérer la situation sur un thème
donné dans tous les États-membres et
ensuite et bien d'identifier quel est
l'intérêt commun et de faire des
propositions qui vont servir de de base
de de discussion donc c'est la
Commission qui fait les propositions oui
on peut même aller plus loin on peut
même dire que la Commission a le
monopole de l'initiative c'est-à-dire
que son rôle sa nature c'est vraiment de
faire des
propositions qui seront ensuite adoptées
par le Parlement européen et et par les
états-membresou qu'on comprenne bien
donc Commission européenne l'initiative
vous l'avez dit des propositions il y a
effectivement ce Parlement européen
c'est peut-être ce qui est le plus le
plus connu pour les citoyens parce que
c'est là où siège les députés oui l'une
des institution donc dont les pouvoirs
se sont considérablement étendus lors
des dernières réformes institutionnelles
maison il faut pas oublier quand même le
Conseil c'estàd les États-membres tout
le monde sait que c'est l'institution
qui légifère avec le Parlement européen
sur les propositions de la Commission il
y a de autres institutions qui sont la
Cour de justice et la cour européenne
des comptes ou Cour de justice
particulier a jouer un rôle important
elle donne le cadre juridique de l'Union
européenne c'est une communauté de de de
droit et elle joue un rôle important
aussi dans l'interprétation du droit
communautaire al je voudrais revenir sur
cette Commission européenne qui désigne
les commissaires ils sont pas ils sont
pas élus par le
peuple la différence des députés
européens c'est juste et en même temps
quelques part il il il le sont le
président de la Commission européenne
est proposé par les chef d'État et de
gouvernement donc vraiment au plus haut
niveau de l'Union européenne et ensuite
chaque état-membre proposera un candidat
commissaire le Parlement européen
intervient dans la mesure où il va
procéder à une double investiture du du
collège de commissairire donc il va
d'abord investir le président de la
commission et ensuite il va investir le
collège dans son ensemble après qu' il
peut retoquer un commissaire qui lui
plairait pas tout à fait ça c'est déjà
arrivé dans le c'est déjà arrivé il le
fait il le fait c'est-à-dire il y a de
mandat le le le Parlement européen avait
rejeté le candidat italien Rocco
boutillone pour commentaire homophobe
durant l'audition au Parlement européen
parce que chaque commissaire avant que
le Parlement européen investisse le
collège Ben est auditionné par par des
commissions parlementaire et lors de la
dernière investiture c'est la
commissaire bulgare candidate
commissaire bulgare qui avait été rejeté
par le Parlement européen al ce qui est
important aussi de dire c'est que le
commissaire européen même s'il est
français par exemple je me tourbe vers
Michel même si les français portent pas
la voix de la France il doit porter de
la voix de l'Europe ça c'est pas des
fois bien bien clair ou bien
compréhensible mais c'est pourtant une
réalité tout à fait c'est c'est non
seulement une réalité mais c'est un
principe fondamental c'est-à-dire que
chaque commissaire est là pour
représenter l'intérêt européen défendre
l'intérêt général n'est pas là pour
défendre les intérêts particuliers ou
les intérêts nation CELI en gros qui
défend les intérêts de son pays c'est
chef d'État qui siège au sein du Conseil
de l'Europe tout à fait c'està-dire
c'est de conseils euh que sont défendus
représenter les intérêts les intérêts
nationaux et ça veut dire qu'à la
Commission européenne du coup on a une
vision on est obligé d'avoir une vision
lointaine on a un regard visionnaire
puisque bah visionnaire dans la mesure
où souvent on regardera les les les
facilement les tendances à long terme en
Europe visionnaire aussi dans le sens où
ça vous offre une perspective européenne
or sur beaucoup de thèmes de société
aujourd'hui vous ne pouvez pas faire une
analyse efficace vous ne pouvez pas agir
sur la réalité sans adopter une
dimension européenne donc sur les
questions de réforme du secteur
financier de politique énergétique de
politique environnementale ben vous
devez trouver des solutions au niveau du
continent on peut agir évidemment au
niveau national mais sur tous ces thèmes
on ne peut avoir pris sur la réalité que
l'échelle du continent je reviens sur
cette Commission européenne aujourd'hui
elle est composée de 28 membres c'est
compliqué compliqué début voilà c'est
compliqué c'est beaucoup c'est-à-dire
que le fonctionnement collégial de
l'institution voudrait qu'il y ait un
nombre plus
limité de commissaires c'est-à-dire que
la le fonctionnement collégial de
l'institution B assure la qualité des
décisions dans la mesure où chaque
commissaire doit consulter ses
homologues quel que soit quel que soit
l'initiative l'institution fonctionne
d'autant mieux en collège que vous avez
un groupe de membres d'ailleurs c'était
jaces Delor qui disait qu'auudelà de 7
commissaires européens ça devenait
difficile de prendre des décisions et là
il y en a 28 donc on se doute que c'est
bien que c'est bien compliqué tout à
fait le 25 mai donc ce sont les
élections européennes elles sont à un
seul tour c'est important et il y a
modification cette fois-ci pour ces
élections c'est-à-dire que du coup il y
aura une représentativité politique plus
importante alors en tout cas la voix du
peuple va être portée différent
différemment la devise la devise
d'ailleurs du Parlement européen pour
ces élections c'est cette fois-ci c'est
diff
alors qu'est-ce qui change pour ces
élections-ci c'est que un protocole du
traité de Lisbonne prévoit que lorsque
les chefs d'État de gouvernement vont
nommer d'abord le candidat président de
la commission et ensuite les candidats
commissaires il doit prendre en compte
le résultat des élections alors ce ce
n'était pas le cas de manière aussi
explicite auparavant ce qui veut dire
pour le Parlement européen très
concrètement que logiquement les chefs
d'État de gouvernement vont devoir
nommer le candidat officiel euh du
groupe politique qui aura gagné les
élections au Parlement européen à la
présidence de la commission donc le
Parlement interprète ce ce protocole de
Lisbonne de manière très précise euh
aujourd'hui pour cette prochaine
élection et bien euh chaque groupe
politique va proposer des candidats va
proposer des programmes et euh le
vainqueur des élections c'est-à-dire le
groupe politique ou le programme qui
aura gagne les élections et bien euh
aura la possibilité de voir son son voir
nommeré président de la commission et
euh aura pour tâ de mettre en œuvre un
programme qui pour le coup sera un
programme politique qui aurait été
proposé pendant la campagne électorale
et on sait que les élections européennes
en général mobilisent pas beaucoup
est-ce que par par cette façon de faire
est-ce que ça peut plus mobiliser les
citoyens qui du coup seront voilà la les
tendances nationales seront mieux
représenté à la Commission européenne
alors oui on peut espérer que le fait
que ces élections aient lieu selon des
mod modalité sensiblement différentes
devrait créer plus d'intérêt de fait
aujourd'hui plusieurs mois avant les
élections européennes il y a déjà
beaucoup de débats sur justement les
candidats qui sont proposés par les
groupes politiques ça permet de
personnaliser aussi les élection
c'est-à-dire de mettre un visage sur
chacun des programmes qui sera proposé
donc idéalement cela devrait favoriser
un intérêt majeur pour les élections
européennes parce que ça rend plus clair
le fait que chaque C CEN là se pronong
sur un candidat sur un programme et donc
fait un choix réel on verra ça à l'issue
à l'issue du 25 mai merci beaucoup Mar
gr d'avoir répondu à nos questions merci
beaucoup merci à vous
merci allez nous poursuivons notre
immersion au sein de la Commission
européenne on va maintenant s'intéresser
à un sujet un peu délicat c'est le
budget de l'Union européenne il est
d'environ 120 milliards d'euros et pour
nous expliquer tout cela nous sommes
allés à la rencontre de Patricio F il
est porte-parole de la programmation
financière et la première question que
l'on a eu envie de lui poser c'est
est-ce que l'Europe est sortie de la
crise on l'écoute répéter des des
déclarations qu'on qu'ont fait le le
président Barroso ou le commissaire reen
qui est en charge des affaires
économiques et financière que il y a
beaucoup d'indicateurs économiques qui
semblent dire que le plus dur de la
crise est derrière nous le budget de
l'Union européenne c'est en moyenne
entre 120 et 130 milliards d'euros 1 %
du produit national brut sur tout le
budget de l'Union européenne il y a à
peine 5 % qui restent à Bruxelles pour
payer en fait les salaires des
fonctionnaires européens les bâtiments
et d'autres choses alors ça veut dire
que 95 % plus ou moins de ce budget
retourne vers les États-membres qui
s'agisse des agriculteurs des étudiants
des chercheurs universitaires qui
s'agisse des petites et moyennes
entreprises il y en a quand même
beaucoup donc avant toute chose c'est
absolument pas un budget pour Bruxelles
le budget de Bruxelles factuellement
c'est faux 2014 2020 une nouvelle
période budgétaire un budget qui va être
revu à la baisse c'est une première
c'est la première fois dans l'histoire
de l'Union européenne qu'on va diminuer
les les budgets deunion européenne c'est
un petit peu embêtant parce que c'est
aussi la première fois qu'on attribue
tellement de compétences supplémentaires
à l'Union européenne il y a le climat
superviser les banques et tout mais bon
voilà on doit faire avec c'était la
décision des États-membres alors s'il
faut couper nous on a proposé la
Commission européenne de surtout pas
couper dans les politiques qui peuvent
promouvoir l'emploi la croissance éc
omique donc en gros on recommande
d'augmenter les financements pour
l'éducation pour la recherche les
sciences le soutien aux petites et
moyennes entreprises une nouvelle
période cela va entraîner aussi des
modifications en matière d'attribution
des budgets européens on a réussi aussi
à convaincre les États-membres et le
Parlement européen qu'à l'avenir il
faudra quand même que les bénéficiaires
de ces financements européens nous
convainquent nous la Commission
européenne que leur projet ou plutôt
leur projet de projet va faire une
différence sur le terrain he que ça sera
bon pour la croissance pour l'emploi on
va aussi suggérer à tous ces
bénéficiaires potentiels on va peut-être
un peu s'éloigner à l'avenir des grands
projets d'infrastructure de d'aéroport
d'autoroute et se concentrer ou plutôt
privilégier les financement pour des
projets où on forme le personnel des
entreprises tout ce qui est recherche
sciences innovation et je crois que
c'est pas mal pour l'avenir de l'Europe
des financements européens sont aussi
disponibles pour les PME et les TPE et
cela ne se sait pas forcément des
bureaux de la représentation de la
Commission européenne sont présents
notamment à Paris dans les ivelines
Europe Direct se situ à
Versailles on a abordé le fonctionnement
de la Commission européenne du Conseil
de l'Europe du Parlement européen on a
parlé du sujet délicat du budget et
maintenant on va aller plus en
profondeur on va s'intéresser à ces
fameux fonds régionaux fonds d'aide
financière apporté par l'Europe les
fameux fonds fitair toutes les exp ition
maintenant avec Luigi nigri l'Europe
finance participe à la réalisation de
tout un nombre de projets qui vont des
projets d'entreprise des projets par
exemple visant à diminuer la quantité de
CO2 améliorer la mobilité
la la gamme des projets qui peuvent être
soutenus par l'Europe elle est très
large évidemment pour faire savoir aux
gens que ces projets existent il faut
aussi mettre la marque de l'Europe et là
il y a encore du travail à faire la
politique régionale d'Europe c'est une
politique qui vise à intervenir
directement dans la vie des gens pour
améliorer leur qualité de vie et surtout
la capacité de créer plus d'emplois et
de richesse surtout aujourd'hui le gros
problème est la création d'emploi et
l'emploi des jeunes les fonds ont
diminué mais reste quand même très
consistant 325 milliards d'euros pour C
ans pour toutes les régions européennes
c'est quand même une somme importante il
y a juste euh la la capacité renforcée
d'intervenir plus dans les secteurs
prioritaire de la recherche et de
l'innovation parce que c'est dans dans
ces domaines là qu'il y a des problèmes
à
résoudre cette émission consacrée aux
institutions européennes est terminée
j'espère que vous aurez appris plein de
choses et je vous rappelle que les
élections européennes ont lieu sur une
journée le dimanche 25 mai alors bon
vote à
vous ceci est une
publicité une publicité vous suggère ce
que vous devez
faire mais cette publicité vous demande
ce que nous devons
faire exercez votre pouvoir choisissez
qui gouvernera l'Europe votez le 25
mai les élections européennes le 25 mai